Hi, this is Joel Blackstock, and you're listening to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. Today we are talking to Martin Gledhill, who's working on his PhD and also a book about Carl Jung's personal project and vacation home, Bollingen Tower. Bollingen Tower is on Lake Zurich, and Jung viewed it in a lot of ways as the culmination of his life's work. Mr. Gledhill is here to talk to us about that. We connected via Zoom while I was on vacation, so bear that in mind. There's places where the connection is a little choppy, and this interview is also available on YouTube if you want to go to the gettherapybirmingham.com YouTube page.
你好，我是乔尔·布莱克斯托克，你正在收听的是 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。今天我们采访的是马丁·格莱德希尔，他正在攻读博士学位，同时也正在撰写一本关于卡尔·荣格的个人项目及度假屋——博林根塔的书。博林根塔位于苏黎世湖畔，荣格在许多方面将其视为他毕生工作的结晶。格莱德希尔先生今天来到这里与我们探讨这个话题。我们在我度假期间通过 Zoom 进行了连线，所以请见谅。在某些地方连接可能有点不稳定，如果你想访问 gettherapybirmingham.com 的 YouTube 页面，这次采访也可以在 YouTube 上观看。
So without further ado, I will roll that now. I'm here with Martin Gledhill, who's an academic who researches Jung architecture and is going to talk about Jung's house in Bollingen, which is kind of a personal project and culminated in the intersection of a whole lot of his lifelong projects and passions. I guess if you want to just kind of start and go over some of your work about Bollingen, I know the listeners will be fascinated. It's not a topic a ton of people know a lot about. So I mean, you're probably in the minority in the world there. Yeah, well, that'd be good.
那么，废话不多说，我们现在就开始吧。我和马丁·格莱德希尔在一起，他是一位研究荣格建筑的学者，他将谈论荣格在博林根的房子，这算是一个个人项目，也是他一生中许多项目和热情的交汇点。我想如果你愿意的话，可以先简单介绍一下你关于博林根的工作，我知道听众们会很感兴趣。这不是一个很多人了解的话题。所以，你在这个领域可能属于少数派。是的，那会很棒。
I mean, it's a kind of bizarre passion that I've got. I suppose I'm a trained architect. So, you know, I've always thought architecture, you know, really could be a bit more meaningful. And then maybe, I don't know, 30, 40 years ago, I started going into therapy, partly because I wasn't very good at relationships. And, and, and I suppose, you know, these two threads, for me have sort of come together. So actually, I made a massive decision to give up my work, give up what I was teaching at university, and just embark on this project.
我的意思是，这是一种我所拥有的奇怪的热情。我想我是一名受过训练的建筑师。所以，你知道，我一直认为建筑确实可以更有意义。然后也许，我不知道，30、40年前，我开始接受心理治疗，部分原因是我不太擅长处理人际关系。而且，我想，这两条线索对我来说已经融合在一起了。所以实际上，我做了一个重大的决定，放弃了我的工作，放弃了我在大学的教职，全身心地投入到这个项目中。
So it's been running for about seven years. And I mean, I suppose the kind of backdrop is that I think therapeutic practice probably could involve place more, you know, place seems to be sort of absent from the discussion, you know, even in the therapy room, and perhaps hope that's not offensive or difficult to anyone. Anyway, I mean, do you find that in dream work, they make room for place in the sense that you're describing? Or do you mean another way that place can intersect with therapy? Well, I suppose in dream work it it can be sort of um amplified more but i think the the role of what you might call psychic place a sense of belonging or you know the presence of where we live particularly obviously it's very very um potent in a home
所以这个项目已经进行了大约七年了。我的意思是，我想背景是这样的：我认为治疗实践可能应该更多地涉及“场所”，你知道，场所似乎在讨论中缺席了，即使是在治疗室里，希望这不会冒犯任何人或让任何人感到困扰。总之，你在梦境工作（dream work）中是否发现他们像你描述的那样为“场所”留出了空间？还是说你指的是场所与治疗相交的另一种方式？嗯，我想在梦境工作中，它可以被某种程度上放大，但我认为你所说的“心理场所”的作用，即一种归属感，或者说我们居住的地方的存在感，在家里显然是非常、非常强烈的。
less so in uh bigger places and maybe more so or most so in religious environments but I think matter if you put it in terms of matter I think it's kind of slightly pushed out from the kind of therapeutic dialogue particularly in analytical psychology in my experience I mean obviously that might be slightly contentious. So I think why Jung's really interesting is that he begins that journey, doesn't he, through alchemy, you know, an engagement with matter, and Marie von Franz sort of carries the torch literally. But if you think about it, you know, it's quite rare for a psychologist to conceive their family home, Kushnacht,
在更大的地方则不那么明显，也许在宗教环境中最为明显。但我认为，如果你从物质的角度来看，我认为它在某种程度上被排挤出了治疗对话，特别是在我的分析心理学经验中。我的意思是，这显然可能有点争议。所以我认为荣格之所以非常有趣，是因为他通过炼金术开启了那段旅程，你知道，与物质的接触，而玛丽·路易丝·冯·弗兰兹（Marie von Franz）实际上接过了火炬。但如果你仔细想想，心理学家构思自己的家庭住宅（库斯纳赫特）是相当罕见的。
and to, well, not exactly build Bollingen, but certainly to begin to build Bollingen. And then, in effect, he's operating as an architect in two places. So over to you, final question of a job. No, I think that's a great intro. I mean, it was an attempt to kind of build something with all of the different tools that Jung had found over his life. I mean, I think he kind of was really hungry
而且，并不是说他完全建造了博林根，但肯定是他开始建造博林根的。然后，实际上，他在两个地方都以建筑师的身份在运作。所以交给你了，最后一个问题。不，我认为这是一个很好的开场白。我的意思是，这是一种尝试，试图用荣格一生中发现的所有不同工具来建造一些东西。我的意思是，我认为他当时真的很渴望。
for a unified theory of everything almost. Yeah, yeah. On the inside of the mind, you know, he wasn't as existentially concerned. It was phenomenological what is going on inside of me and other people know, he wasn't as, he wasn't as existentially concerned. It was phenomenological. What is going on inside of me and other people that I see and that they feel and that I feel. And a lot of that intersected with Bollingen, but it's not very well understood.
几乎渴望一个统一的万物理论。是的，是的。在心灵内部，你知道，他并不那么关注存在主义。它是现象学的，即我内心和他人身上发生了什么，你知道，他并不那么关注存在主义。它是现象学的。我内心以及我所看到的、他们所感受到的和我所感受到的一切，到底发生了什么。其中很多都与博林根交织在一起，但人们对此了解并不深。
And you saying that the gateway to alchemy is kind of the bridge between the matter and the mind, because you're working on things of the mind through metaphors of matter and science. That's a great intro. I never thought of it that way. It's kind of the unfinished work of analytical psychology, which to a degree Marie von Franz, you know, sort of picked up on. But I suppose, you know, coming at the tower from a different angle, I mean, I have to say that the Jung family have been absolutely wonderful
你说炼金术的门户是物质与心灵之间的桥梁，因为你正在通过物质和科学的隐喻来研究心灵的事物。这是一个很好的开场白。我从来没有那样想过。这算是分析心理学未完成的工作，在某种程度上，玛丽·路易丝·冯·弗兰兹（Marie von Franz）接手了。但我认为，从不同的角度来看待这座塔，我必须说荣格家族一直非常慷慨地与我谈论它，你知道，进入这座塔是相当困难的，我的意思是，这是一个私人住宅，所以，跳过它，我认为家庭的隐私和财产需要得到尊重，他们当然尊重荣格的遗产，这就是为什么它在某种意义上是无法进入的。即使你被允许进入，你也完全不能拍摄内部，对吗？是这样吗？嗯，你可以进入，我已经去过四次了，你可以下楼，但如果你愿意的话，有一种真正的“上方”的感觉。这座塔里有人们没见过的壁画之类的东西吗？这是真的吗？这座塔里有人们没见过的壁画之类的东西，对吗？
in their generosity of talking to me about it and you know it it's quite difficult to get into the town and I mean it's a private home so you know jumping over it so the privacy and property of the family I think of you know need to be respected and certainly they respect uh jung's legacy just why a lot of it is is kind of inaccessible in all senses of the word you can't photograph the inside at all even if you're allowed in correct is that is that right well you can go into the i've been there four times now and you can go downstairs but there's a real sense of the above, if you like. The tower has murals and things that people haven't seen. Is that correct? The tower has murals and things that people haven't seen, is that right?
是的，是的。而且，你知道，我会说，我可能只了解其中的25%到30%，我绝对尊重那份遗产。我的意思是，荣格去世时，他希望这座塔保持原样，所以，你知道，我经历过一些非常有趣的时刻，有一天我到达那里，发现那个“灯丝石”（filament stone）正被一个荣格学者当作非常好的野餐桌使用，我想，哦，天哪，这种神圣的石头，你知道，并没有不尊重。它只是家庭继承人的一个工作、生活的隐居处。
Yeah, yeah. And there are, you know, there's, you know, I would suggest, I probably am only aware of maybe 25, 30 percent of it and I absolutely respect that legacy I mean really the the Jung family well when Jung died he wanted the tower to be left kind of as it was so you know I've had some really amusing moments where I arrived one day and the filament stone was uh providing a very good picnic table, for a youngie, and I thought, oh my, this kind of sacred stone, which, you know, there was no disrespect. It's just a working, living retreat for the heirs of the family.
所以从不同的角度来看，我认为《回忆、梦、思考》（MDR）中的叙述是不完整的。因为像萨姆·德萨尼（Sam Dersani）这样的人在弄清楚哪些部分是谁写的工作上做了很多努力，没有对阿尼拉·雅菲（Aniela Jaffé）不敬，但我认为它有时是不完整的，有点不准确，你知道，它基本上是被整理过的。我的意思是，其中有一些章节是家人从未想过要出版的。是的。所以它客观上是不完整的，对吧？我的意思是，他写了一些不在里面的东西。是的，但即使是这样，我的意思是，你知道，所以它客观上是不完整的，对吧？我的意思是，他写了一些不在里面的东西。是的，但即使是这样，我的意思是，你知道，所以它在两个方面是不完整的，A，有缺失的章节，所以你。
So coming at it from a different angle, I think the account in Memories, Dreams and Reflections is incomplete, I think I would say. And because people like Sam Dersani have done a lot of work on working out which bits were written by who, no no disrespect to Anil Yaffe, but I think it's incomplete at times a little bit inaccurate you know it's been tidied up basically. Well I mean there's there's chapters of it that the family never wanted published. Yeah. So it is it is objectively incomplete right I mean he wrote things that are not in it. Yeah but even I mean you know so it is it is objectively incomplete right i mean he wrote things that are not in it yeah but even i mean you know so it's incomplete in two ways a there's missing chapters so you
知道，例如，嗯，你知道关于托妮·沃尔夫（Toni Wolff）的记忆，你知道，我认为艾伦·埃姆斯（Alan Elms）称之为——是埃姆斯还是某人称之为“阿尔特化”（altification）——但我感兴趣的是，这一章本身，第八章“塔”，并不是真正关于塔的。如果你仔细想想，它只用了大约三页来谈论塔。然后它就转向了祖先和更广泛的问题。这没关系。但你认为，从某种意义上说，塔的传记需要被书写吗？博林根塔的传记？是的，我的意思是，实际上这个想法来自荣格的曾孙贾斯特·赫尼（Just Hurni），我当时——这听起来有点做作——我当时正在。
know for example um you know the memory of tony wolf um you know there's this i think alan elms called it was it was elams or someone called it the altification um but i suppose what I'm interested in is that the chapter itself, chapter 8, the Tower, is not really about the Tower. If you think about it, it's only about three pages to talk about the Tower. Then it goes off into ancestors and sort of much wider issues. And that's kind of fine. But do you think, well, the biography of the Tower, in a sense, i think needs to be written the biography of bollingen tower yeah i mean actually that idea came from um just herney who is young sam great grandson and i i was sounds a bit posy this but i was chatting to
在洛布秀（Lobe show）和他聊天，他只是说，哦，我想写塔的传记。我想他的意思是访问过塔的人的传记。这个家庭一直有荣格感兴趣的人在打扰他们的隐私，我只是看到过一些报道，人们走到它面前，他们说，好吧，你知道，你可以进来。
him in the lobe show and he just said, oh, I want to write the biography of the tower. What I think he meant was the biography of the people who visited the tower. The family has Jungian, you know, interested people kind of disturbing their privacy all the time from one of, I've just seen accounts where people wander up to it and they say, okay, you know, you can come in,
你可以看到它的一部分，他们很亲切。人们一直在窥视它，你知道吗？是的。我的意思是，这是一个很好的表达方式，乔尔，那种优雅。我的意思是，有一次，我和一个朋友划船到塔边，因为我想从湖上，从苏黎世湖拍摄它。这些人向我们挥手，我们以为他们基本上是在挥手让我们走开。但后来我们意识到他们实际上是在挥手。
you can see part of it and they're gracious. People are peeping at it all the time, you know? Yeah. I mean, that's a very nice way of putting it, Joel, the grace. I mean, one, on one occasion, a mate of mine were rowing up to the tower because I wanted to photograph it from the lake, from Lake Zurich. And these people were waving at us and we thought they were basically waving for us to go away. But then we realized they were actually waving
让我们靠岸。所以我们着陆了，他们非常热情，但同时也保持着一种克制，这不仅仅是开放参观。所以，我认为在“场所”、心理场所的背景下讲述塔的故事是很有趣的。我认为《回忆、梦、思考》（MDR）是不完整的，实际上，你知道，在荣格家族中有六位建筑师。他的叔叔是建筑师，他的堂兄是建筑师，他的儿子、女婿、孙子安德烈亚斯（Andreas）和曾孙丹尼尔（Daniel）。所以有这样一种，我把这些信息归功于。
for us to come ashore. So we kind of landed and they were incredibly hospitable, but with a containment in equal measure, it wasn't just sort of open house. So, I think the story of the tower is interesting to tell in the context of place, psychic place. I think MDR is incomplete and actually, you know, in the Jung family there are six architects. His uncle was an architect, his cousin was an architect, his son, his son-in-law, his grandson Andreas and his great-grandson Daniel. So there's this kind of, I owe this information
安德烈亚斯，他的孙子，你知道，有这样一种建筑线索，在某种意义上这与我们的考古学有关，你知道荣格对考古学感兴趣，并想成为一名考古学家，所以这是一种反向考古学，不是吗？是的，是的，好吧，那种向下挖掘，建造东西以便被未来发现，而不是发现过去留下的东西，是的，是的。所以，你知道，这绝对是令人着迷的。目前，我大概写了92,000字。我只是不断地，你知道，如果你回想那些形成性的地方，你知道，劳芬（Laufen）、莱茵瀑布（Rhine Falls）、克莱因-洪尼根（Klein-Hunnigan）。
to Andreas, his grandson, you know there's this kind of architectural thread um which in some sense this is linked to our archaeology you know that jung was interested in archaeology and wanted to be an archaeologist so it's a kind of reverse archaeology isn't it yeah yeah well then sort of digging down building the thing to be discovered by the future instead of discovering the thing you know that left by the past yeah yeah so you know it's absolutely left by the past. Yeah, yeah. So, you know, it's absolutely fascinating. And at the moment, I'm probably about 92,000 words. And I just keep on, you know, if you think back to the formative places, you know, Laufen, Rhine Falls, Klein-Hunnigan,
你知道，在所有这些地方都有塔的线索。你知道，当他沿着莱茵河行走，看到大船驶来，并建造了一座防御森严的城堡时的行走幻想。他基本上一直在构建“场所”，阁楼，阁楼里的模特。但《回忆、梦、思考》（MDR）中似乎发生的事情是，这些地方被某种程度上背景化了。你知道，出现在前景的是心理学、神学、哲学方面的推论。
you know, in all of these places are clues to the tower. You know, his walking fantasy when he walks along the Rhine when he sees the big ship coming along and constructs a kind of well fortified castle. He's basically constructing place all the time, the attic, the mannequin in the attic. But what seems to happen in MDR is that these places are sort of backgrounded. You know, what comes to the foreground are psychological or theological, philosophical kind of extrapolations.
但“场所”却以某种方式丢失了。这就是我感觉我的工作，如果你愿意的话，就是追随他的足迹。嗯哼。这意味着经常去瑞士。当然。所以交给你了，乔尔。也许有些人对荣格很熟悉。
But the place is somehow lost. That's what I feel my job, if you like, is to do, is to follow his tracks, if you like. Mm-hmm. Which means going to Switzerland a lot. Sure. So over to you, Joel. And maybe some people have a familiarity with Jung
但可能对博林根了解不多。我的意思是，你无法讲述书中所有的故事，但你能给我们简要介绍一下他与那个地方的关系吗？是的。好吧，本质上，起初，如果你相信《回忆、梦、思考》（MDR），博林根大约在1922、23年左右出现，就在他母亲去世后。现在他请他的儿子，或者说是未来的女婿，沃尔特·尼亚斯（Walter Niasse），一位非常有成就的现代建筑师，去勾勒一种原始小屋。最初他想让它建成中世纪风格的建筑，对吧？是这样吗？而艾玛说不，它需要更现代一些。
but maybe don't know a lot about Bollingen. I mean, you can't tell the whole story that you're telling in the book, but could you give us kind of a brief history of his relationship with that place? Yeah. Well, essentially, at the beginning, if you're to believe MDR, Bollingen sort of emerges around 1922, 23, just after his mother's death. Now he asked his son, or son-in-law to be, Walter Niasse, who was a very accomplished modern architect, to sketch out a kind of primitive hut. Initially he wanted it to be built in like medieval type architecture, right? Is that right? And Emma says no, it needs to be more contemporary.
他稍微改变了一下风格。据我所知没有那么多，但我认为他想让它成为一个非常原始的小屋。你知道，单层的圆形住宅，你知道，就像你在东非会发现的那样，他在20年，无论哪一年，25年，不是吗？27年，是的，他什么时候去的非洲？25年，嗯，25、26年，所以它立即被改编，并且需要另一层，但实际上有一个背景故事，因为他过去常沿着苏黎世湖航行。
And he changes the style a little bit. Not so much, not as far as I'm aware, but I think he wanted it to be a very primitive hut. The, you know, single story kind of round dwelling, you know, much like you would find in East Africa that he visits in 20, whatever it is 25 isn't it 27 yeah when did he go to Africa 25 um 25 26 um and so it's immediately adapted and and requires another another floor but actually there is a sort of back story because he used to sail down uh Lakes Urick
嗯，这大约需要半天，四分之三天，取决于风向，到一个叫林特岛（Linth Island）的地方，就在最底部。他过去常和一个我认为是精神科医生的朋友在那里露营。后来，家人也开始加入他的露营行列，他真的很想让塔在那里建立或建造。所以，你知道，我想大概艾玛对他说，好吧，你看，你知道，这挺好的。
um which takes about maybe half a day, three quarters of a day, depending on the wind, to a place called the Linth Island, which is right at the bottom. And he used to camp there with a mate who was a psychiatrist, I think. And then after a while, the family used to join him camping and he really wanted the tower to be founded or to be built there. So, you know, I think probably Emma said to him, well, look, you know, it's kind of fine,
所有这些露营，卡尔，但是，你知道，我们需要一些更永久的东西，你知道，考虑到库斯纳赫特（Kushnacht）是一座相当豪华的房子。他很迷恋水边的空间，你知道。是的，他是。是的，是的。他小时候在康斯坦茨湖参观的那座城堡，你知道，巩固了那种忠诚。
all this camping, Carl, but, you know, we kind of need something a bit more permanent, you know, given that Kushnick's quite a luxurious house. He was kind of enamored with spaces by water, you know. Yes, he was. Yeah, yeah. The castle that he visited as a young boy on Lake Constance, you know, sort of cemented that kind of allegiance.
总之，当地人不太热衷于他购买这块土地，因为他被视为某种引号里的“巫医”，所以他的朋友说，为什么你不看看更近一点的地方？基本上，博林根现在所在的地方大约是20分钟的独木舟路程，我身体不太好，所以我花了20分钟，他可能划船花了四分之一英里，有一天他着陆了，一个叫汉斯的小男孩迎接了他，他说，好吧，你知道，我有兴趣买这块地。他们成为了非常好的朋友，他成为了一个类似干儿子的角色，在镇上帮了他很多忙。所以塔，你知道，第一阶段建成了，然后大约四年后，附件，也就是所谓的附件或塔式附件建成了，所以如果我诚实的话，它确实是一个度假屋，首先它是一个度假屋，但是。
Anyway, the locals weren't too keen on him buying the land as a kind of inverted commas witch doctor and so his friend said well why don't you look around a bit closer and basically where Bollingen is now is about a 20 minute canoe ride I'm not very fit so it took me 20 minutes I might've taken him quarter mile by cell and he landed there one day and a young boy called Hans greeted him and he said well you know I'm interested in buying this land they become very good friends he became a kind of surrogate son who helped him a lot in the town so the tower you know the first stage gets built and then about four years later uh the annex what's called the annex or the tower like annex gets built so it's really a holiday home if i was really honest it's a holiday home first of all but
它不现代，没有电，我的意思是，它是永久性的，你从湖里抽水，你在烧木头的炉子上做饭，我的意思是，这是一个非常、非常质朴的远离科技的隐居处。是的，是的，现在仍然如此，你知道，水是从湖里抽上来的，有一个外部厕所，没有电，嗯，所以这座建筑开始时确实是一个度假屋或仓库，它获得了这个附件，然后四年后它获得了第三阶段，被称为“精神之塔”，只有荣格有钥匙，而且它非常。
it's not modern there's not electricity i mean it's it's a permanent you pump your water you cook on a wood burning stove i mean it's very uh very rustic retreat from technology yeah yeah and that still is the case you know that you have the water is pumped up from the lake there's an external toilet and there's no electricity um so the building becomes it starts really as a store a holiday home or a storehouse it becomes it acquires this annex and then it acquires a third phase four years later which is called the spiritual tower which only Jung had a key to and it was very
封闭，我想那是一个非常……那是他的私人书房，当家人不能进去的时候。是的，所以从某种意义上说，他不断地撤退，他从家人那里撤退，他向上撤退，然后四年后。
closed and I imagine to be a very... It was his private study when the family wasn't able to go in Yeah, so in a way he's constantly retreating he's retreating from his family he's retreating up and then four years after that,
虽然我认为这不准确，所谓的凉廊（loggia）和庭院被添加了，但我认为当你观察石头的接缝和各种……时，那实际上是两个独立的阶段。他说他自己切割了塔的石头，不是整个房子，而是塔本身，或者他与它有一些互动，这是真的吗？好吧，我有照片，我想他和他的儿子弗朗茨（一位建筑师）以及沃尔特·尼亚斯（Walter Niasse），也许还有汉斯，可能把这些石墙堆到了大约一米高，因为你可以看到在那之后风格的变化。现在，墙壁至少有一米厚，所以没有工匠技能独自建造它。
although I think this is inaccurate, what's called the loggia and the courtyard are added, but I think those are actually two separate phases when you look at the joints in stone and various kind of... And he said he cut the stones for the tower, not the whole house, but the tower himself, or he had some interaction with it is that right well i i've got pictures of i reckon that he and his son france who's an architect and uh walter nias and maybe hans as well probably lift um built these stone walls up to about maybe a metre because you can see a change in style after that. Now, the walls are about at least a metre thick, so to build that on your own with no artisanal skill
是一个很大的挑战。所以我认为他们基本上放弃了，但他们变得现实了，他们雇了一些意大利建筑工人来建造它。所以它开始实际上由其他人建造。如果你想想，在这段时间里，荣格经常不在。他在非洲，在美国。
is a big ask. So I think they kind of just gave up, but they just became realistic and they hired some Italian builders to build it. So it starts to be in effect built by others. And if you think about it during this time, Jung is away a lot. He's in Africa, he's in America,
后来他在印度，你知道，他真的在旅行，他真的在走。所以，你知道，谁是塔的作者呢？是的，嗯，最终在50年代初，嗯，他增加了一层，有时被称为第五集，实际上我认为是由他的儿子弗朗茨设计的，那是一个更开放的空间，嗯，其他的空间非常阴郁（chthonic），非常封闭，非常神秘，正如你所指出的，相当中世纪。所以它基本上有这五个阶段。你可能会争辩说“灯丝石”是第六阶段，或者你知道，4加1。你能告诉我们关于“灯丝石”的事吗？它可能不是顶石，而是末石，是他作为某种结局制作的最后一块石头？好吧，供应的采石场，嗯，博林根有一系列的采石场，故事是这样的，供应的采石场被要求供应一块角石，实际上应该是三角形的，结果却作为立方体到达了，石匠说，好吧，你需要把它拿走，它完全错了。而荣格，那个非常有直觉的人。
later on he's in India, you know, she's really traveling, he's really going to going. So, you know, who's the author of the tower in a way yeah um and then eventually in um uh in the uh in the 50 in the early 50s um he adds a third story or sometimes known as the fifth episode which actually is i think is designed by his son france and that's a much more open space um you of the other spaces are very chthonic, very enclosed, very mysterious and as you've indicated quite medieval. So it's basically got these five stages. You might argue that the filament stone is a kind of sixth stage or you know a
发现了它，并立即在某种意义上识别出了它的电荷，它的心理电荷。所以它是一个立方体，一块立方体石头，而且，你知道，与炼金术有联系。他雕刻了它。他雕刻了它的三个面。
four plus. Can you tell us about the filament stone which is maybe like not the capstone but the end stone it's the last piece that he makes as kind of an ending? Well the quarry that supplied, well there's a series of quarries in Bollingen and the story goes that the quarry that supplied, were asked to supply a cornstone, which actually was supposed to be triangular, arrived as a cube and the Mason said, well, you need to take it away, it's just wrong. And Jung sort of, the very intuitive man,
所以他真的对四元性（quaternity）的概念很感兴趣，你知道，三加一的模式。所以一面是空白的。一面有一个图形，一个圆圈围绕着一个图形。曼陀罗吗？它有点像曼陀罗，嗯，它可能不是曼陀罗，它更多是，我永远无法发音，那个“Telephorus”，但你知道中间有这个图形，还有各种其他的拉丁语和希腊语短语。
spotted it and immediately, in a sense, recognised its kind of charge, its psychic charge. So it's a cube, a cubic stone, and, you know, has links to kind of alchemy. And he carved it. He carved three sides of it.
但那种基督教的共鸣很有趣，因为那种被丢弃的石头，不想要的石头，是基督的一种隐喻。建筑师拒绝的石头，是他与荣格交谈时的一个想法，当时建筑师正在拒绝这块石头。是的，是的。所以它在塔的围墙之外。冬天的时候，他们会在上面放一个小铜盖，这实际上就是曾经有野餐桌的地方，你知道，这真是太棒了。而且你。
So he was really interested in the idea of the quaternity, you know, the three plus one pattern. So one side is blank. One side has the figure of, a figure with a circle around it. With a mandala? It's kind of a mandala, well it's probably not a mandala, it's more, I can never pronounce it, the teleforce, but you know this kind of figure in the middle and various other Latin and Greek phrases.
知道荣格经常被拍到坐在它旁边，他在《回忆、梦、思考》（MDR）中辩称，他所有的工作都浓缩在那块石头里，他想说的一切都在那块石头里，所以它是一个非常珍贵的，对某些人来说是神圣的物体。然后他雕刻了塔的其他元素。他雕刻了一只熊，这与俄罗斯有关，但也同样可以与圣迈恩拉德（Saint Meinrad）联系起来，他的崇拜属于那个地区。珀伽索斯（Pegasus），还有坟墓，给他妻子的雕刻，所以它是一座外部纹身很多的建筑。所以它是……他开始把它当作日记来用。是的，那是一个非常可爱的想法，乔尔，它是一种，它是一本日记，它是一个。
But the kind of Christian resonance is interesting because the kind of discarded stone, the unwanted stone is a kind of trope for Christ. The stone the builder rejected is an idea as he spoke to Jung when the builder is rejecting the stone. Yeah, yeah. So it's outside the the curtilage of the tower. During the winter they put a little sort of copper cap on it and this is actually where there was a picnic table, you know, it's kind of wonderful. And you
记忆辅助工具，它是一个身体，它在某种意义上并不是真正的建筑，但当然它是一本日记，它是一个记忆辅助工具，它是一个身体，它在某种意义上并不是真正的建筑。当然它是一座建筑，但它更多，你知道，显然我有点沉迷于它，所以我可能把一些东西读进去了，但它有一种非常明确的“场所感”。这些雕刻和绘画，以及它整体的黑暗感，非常、非常诱人。它确实是，你知道，字面上的黑暗，它是你无法看到内部的东西，要么是因为你进不去，要么是因为它是由蜡烛和灯照亮的，它是一座城堡。是的，我的意思是，附件部分，第二阶段，稍微开放一点，因为它有一个大的谷仓门。
know Jung is often pictured sitting by it and he argues in MDR that all his work was encapsulated in that stone everything he had to say was in that stone so it's a very precious and for some sacred object. And then he carved other elements of the tower. He carved a bear, which has been associated with Russia, but could equally be associated with Saint Minrad, whose cult belongs to that area. Pegasus, there's the tomb, the engraving to his wife, so it's a very tattooed building externally. So it's... He's starting to use it almost as a diary. Yeah, that's a really lovely idea Joel, it's a kind of, it's a diary, it's a
这在第三阶段被稍微包含进去了。但正如你所暗示的，它在各个意义上都是黑暗的。你知道，有某种……实际上我自己的工作一直在梳理所有不同的传记，并提取人们的小记忆，以便拼凑出缺失的部分，如果你愿意的话，所以这就像一个巨大的侦探故事。嗯，我知道萨姆·沙达尼（Sam Shadani）和詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）在《哀悼死者》（Lament for the Dead）一书中，他们谈论的一件事是，荣格正在撤退到塔的最高处，那是对他来说最私人的地方，没有人被允许进入，甚至连情妇托妮·沃尔夫（Toni Wolff）或他的妻子艾玛也不行。你知道，也许他们看到了，但那是他的空间。
memory aid, it's a body, it's kind of not really a building in a way, but of course it's a diary, it's a memory aid, it's a body, it's kind of not really a building in a way. Of course it is a building, but it's much more, you know, obviously I'm slightly addicted to it, so I perhaps read things into it, but it has a very definite sense of place. And these engravings and paintings and just the whole the darkness of it is very very alluring it is you know literally dark it's something you can't see inside of either because you can't get inside or because it's lit by candles and lamps, it's a castle. Yeah, I mean, the annex bit, the second phase, is a bit more open because it had a big sort of barn door,
与此同时，他为自己不被世界理解而悲伤。所以他向内撤退，但也为自己不被更多人理解，或者无法以某种方式带出他的内在愿景而感到悲伤和难过。他在塔顶的内在愿景中花费时间，帮助他澄清、提炼和处理它，这样他就可以带出一个启示给人们，不仅他可以有内在的体验，而且许多荣格的伦理，他的个人伦理是，你可以撤退到无意识中，你可以撤退到自我中，但你需要为其他人带回一些东西。你需要带回一些不仅是为了你，而是为了每个人的东西。
which is slightly subsumed in the third phase. But it's sort of dark, as you've alluded to, in all senses. You know, there's kind of... And really my own work has been going through all the different biographies and pulling out little memories that people have to in order to get to sort of piece together the missing bits if you like so it's sort of a big detective story um well and i know samu um samshadani and james hillman in the lament for the dead book one of the things that they talk about is that Jung is retreating into the highest part of the tower, which is like the most personal spot for him where no one is allowed in, not even the Mistress Tony Wolfe or his wife Emma as much. You know, maybe they see it, but it's his space.
我认为那本书中最大的论点之一是，他从中带出来的是，我们不仅有义务超越父母未活出的生活，超越你知道我们父母没有完全完成他们的生活和自我的地方，我们还有责任超越人类文化中所有死者的未活出的生活，所有人类还没有处理的事情，所有人类还没有做的事情，我们需要找到一种方式来超越我们动物的本性，我们需要找到一种方式来超越我们的偏见，不仅是个人阴影，还有文化和人类的阴影，我认为他们在《哀悼死者》中的论点是，这就是他在《红书》中所说的，而其中很多是在他沉思塔里的壁画并绘制它们时完成的。是的，不，那说得很好，乔尔。
And at the same time, he's grieving that he's not understood by the world. So he's retreating inward, but also grieving and sad that he is not understood by more people or can't bring his internal vision out in a way. And him spending time in that internal vision of the top of the tower helps him clarify it and rarefy it and process it so that he can bring out a revelation to people so that not just he can have the experience internal, but a lot of the Jungian ethics, his personal ethics was that you can retreat into the unconscious, you can retreat into the self, but you need to bring something back for other people. You need to bring something back that is not just for you, but for everyone.
我认为，事实上，桑托斯·萨尼（Shantosani）认为，确实，塔——我同意他的观点——塔是《红书》的延续。是的，你知道，它是一座三维的塔，《红书》以某种方式从塔中带出来，即使他不是在那里工作，他也在“自我”中度过了形成性的时间，然后把它带出来。那是遗物，你知道吗？是的。好吧，实际上，如果你看《红书》中的很多图片，我的意思是，特别是堡垒的曼陀罗。
And I think one of the biggest arguments in that book is that what he brings out of it is that it's not just that we have the obligation to go past the unlived life of the parent and to go past you know where our parents didn't quite um finish their lives and selves but we have the responsibility to go past the unlike life of all of the dead in human culture all the things that humanity has not dealt with all the things that humanity has not done yet and that we need to find a way to transcend you know our animal nature we need to find a way to transcend um our bias and our not just personal shadow but our cultural and human shadow and that that's kind of their argument i think in moment for the dead is that that's what he is saying with the red book um and a lot of that is is made while he's contemplating the murals in that tower and painting them yeah no that's very well put joel
他，嗯，实际上有一个，我不记得是哪一章了，我想是第二章，嗯，有一个元素叫“湖边的城堡”，实际上我认为它的日期是1913年。它几乎就是塔的愿景，就像你知道20、30、40年后一样，所以我认为这是一种持续的，你知道，它几乎超越了时间，在《红书》的意象和塔本身之间存在着这种滑动。所以，嗯，我本来想说点别的，但它刚刚从我的脑海中消失了。嗯，是的，我知道，是的，我的意思是，所谓的“精神之塔”，也就是第三阶段，1931年，我认为与拉文纳（Ravenna），他去拉文纳的旅行有很大的联系。
i think that the in fact shantosani argues that really that the tower and i agree with him the tower is a continuation of the red book yeah you know it's a three-dimensional tower the red book is brought out of the tower in a certain way even if he's not working on it there he's spending the formative time in the cell fair and then bringing it out. That's the relic, you know? Yeah. Well, actually, if you look at quite a lot of the pictures in the Red Book, I mean, particularly the Mandala one of the fort,
但我认为那是他的内在场所，你最连接的木材场所，顶部的第五集要透明得多，它有一个木框架，所以它对湖是开放的，所以你得到了这种美味的……这不是真正的二元论，因为它以某种方式超越了它，你知道，有这种等量的封闭开放。我的意思是，正如你早些时候所说，我认为他对世界的幻灭，你知道，他用像梅林（Merlin）那样的话来说，他不得不撤退到森林里的塔中，因为世界太愚蠢了，无法理解。我认为这是一种，好吧，吉格里奇（Giegrich）对那种放弃世界的行为非常批评。
the, he's, well, there's actually one, I can't remember the chapter, I think it's chapter two um there's a there's an element called the castle by the lake which actually i think the date of that is 1913. it's pretty well a vision of the tower as in you know like you know 20 30 40 years later so i think it's a kind of ongoing you know it almost transcends time that there's this kind of slippage between the imagery of the the red book and the um uh the tower itself um so um i was gonna say something else and it's just gone out of my mind um yeah i know the the yeah it's i mean really what's called the spiritual tower, which is the, let's call it the third phase, 1931, I think has quite a lot of link to Ravenna, his trip to Ravenna.
你知道，等于某种“心理迪士尼乐园”，我认为这相当严厉。而且他并不孤单，你知道，像里尔克（Rilke）、赖内·马利亚·里尔克（Rainer Maria Rilke）或爱尔兰诗人叶芝（Yeats）这样的人，他们都撤退到塔中。所以这是一种战后模式。而且我认为，对于荣格，大卫·塔西（David Tacey）在我们上次采访中指出的事情之一是，荣格从印度教中借用了许多想法。其中一个意象是婆罗门（Brahman）和阿特曼（Atman）之间的关系，即自我和上帝有一种关系，并通过宗教融合在一起。
But I think that is his inward place, you the most connected timber place the fifth episode at the top is much more transparent and it has a timber frame so it's kind of open to the lake so you've got this kind of delicious um it's not really a dualism because it sort of transcends it you know there's this kind of closed openness in equal measure i mean as you said earlier on that I think his disenchantment with the world, you know he puts in terms of like Merlin he had to retreat to a tower in the wood you know because the world was too damn stupid to sort of understand. I think it is a kind of, well, Giegrich has been very critical of that kind of renouncing of the world,
但是，或者仪式，或者任何你称之为“阈限空间”的东西。但我认为另一个没有得到那么多关注，没有被谈论得那么多，他从印度教中汲取的是，印度教中有“达摩”（Dharma）和“莫克沙”（Moksha）的概念，即你必须进行世界放弃，放弃你的财产，流浪并从世界撤退到森林中。那是灵性的一部分，但维持世界、生儿育女、抚养家庭、救济穷人、为社会做出贡献、运用你的智慧也是如此。这也是作为宗教人士的责任，所以它们之间的关系。
you know, equals sort of psycho Disneyland, which is pretty harsh, I think. And he's not alone, you know, people like Rilke, Rainer Maria Rilke, or the Irish poet Yeats, they all retreat to to the powers. So there is a kind of post-war pattern. And I think, too, Jung, one of the things David Tacey pointed out on our last interview was that Jung borrows a lot of ideas from Hinduism. And one of the images is that relationship between Brahman and Atman, that the self and God have a relationship and are through religion merged together,
在印度教传统中，很多人说，好吧，你在生命开始时做这件事，在结束时你进入森林，或者好吧，你做这件事，然后你获得实现，你把它带回生活中，你知道，他们尝试，因为这些是对立的，但这些对立的张力是荣格感兴趣的东西。我有点在博林根看到了这一点，他在撤退到自己的同时，也在试图制定一些东西来带出自己。我不知道这是否有意义。
but, or ritual or whatever, you know, whatever you want to call it, liminal space. But I think another one that doesn't get as much, it's not talked about as much that he takes from Hinduism is that there's the idea of Dharma and M moksha in Hinduism that you have to have a world renunciation, giving up your belongings, wandering and retreating from the world into the woods. That is part of spirituality, but so is the world sustaining, having children, raising a family, giving to the poor, contributing to society, using your intellect. That also is the way that you as a responsibility of the religious person so the relationship between those
不，绝对有。当你谈到这一点时，我想到了两件事。第一件事颠倒了这个故事。他变成了一个商人，不是吗？然后回来，你知道，那个故事。但更强有力的是，我认为，布鲁德·克劳斯（Bruder Klaus），那位瑞士神秘主义者，马克·吐温（Mark Twain）对此相当俏皮。
and in the Hindu tradition there's a lot of some people say well you do this at the beginning of your life and at the end you go into the woods or well you do this and then you take the realization and you bring it back into life and you know they try and because these are opposites but the tension of those opposites is something that was interesting to Jung. And I kind of see some of that in Bollinger, that he's retreating into himself at the same time that he's trying to formulate something to bring out of himself. I don't know if that makes sense.
关于他，因为他是一位有妻子和10个孩子的圣人，然后当他50岁时，他只是离开了家，所以你知道，实际上荣格谈论布鲁德·克劳斯很多，这是平衡，你知道，实际上家庭生活和孤独生活，嗯，它分裂是不可避免的，不是吗？在某种程度上，库斯纳赫特（Kushnacht）和博林根，当他在晚上写《红书》时，你知道，当他在看病人并与他的孩子和家人共度时光时，他说这是锚，他的家人和孩子是拯救他免于精神病的锚，当他正在探索精神病发作时。是的，我想我们应该记住，实际上。
No, absolutely. I think there's two things that come to mind when you talk about that. The first inverts the story. It becomes a businessman, doesn't it? And then returns, you know, that story. But more potently, I think, Bruder Klaus, the Swiss mystic, who Mark Twain was quite playfully,
我并不是带着任何愤世嫉俗的意思，博林根是一个度假屋，实际上很多照片，你知道，孩子们在玩耍，他坐在湖边，你知道，在玩水，所以你知道，它不是那种对家庭生活的剔除。它不是教堂，它不是，它不应该是。它是家庭的隐居处。是的。而且，你知道，我想这就是为什么他必须在隐居处内找到一个隐居处，如果你愿意的话，这就是你的观点。
playful about because he was a saint who had a wife and 10 kids and then when he was 50 he just kind of left home so you know and actually Jung talks about Broderick House quite a lot it's that balancing of you know in effect family life and and the solitary life um it's kind of inevitable that it splits isn't it in a way Christian Acton and um bollingen when he's writing the red book in the evenings you know while he's seeing patients and spending time with his children and family which he says is an anchor his family and his children were an anchor that saved him from psychosis while he was exploring a psychotic episode yeah i suppose what we should remember though that actually
是的。你知道，某种向上走。我的意思是，我猜，我的意思是，他过去常挂一面黄旗，部分是为了让他的邻居，实际上是驱赶他们的孩子，因为他们会过来敲门。黄旗意味着，你知道，不，你知道，我在写作。你知道，只是……我不知道这一点，是的。是的，所以有这些信号。而且我认为，你知道，包括凉廊在内的围墙。
and I don't mean this with any cynicism that Bollinger is a holiday home and actually a lot of photographs you know the kids are playing he's sitting by the lake you know playing with the water so you know it isn't this kind of culling of family life. It's not a church it's not it's not supposed to be. It's a retreat for a family. Yeah. And, you know, I suppose that's why he has to find a retreat within a retreat, if you like, which was your point.
真的，他描述为，我感到需要一块围起来的土地，但实际上他可能厌倦了像我这样的人沿着湖边走过来说，哦，那是卡尔·荣格和他的妻子。所以他和爱因斯坦也在博林根度过时光，喝红酒，谈论物理学，并最终提出了共时性（synchronicity）理论，不是吗？是的，好吧，那是爱因斯坦的泡利（Paoli），不是吗？我认为沃尔夫冈·泡利（Wolfgang Pauli），我以为爱因斯坦是……我不知道，我知道，是的，所以我不是想……我的意思是，我不确定，但我不知道泡利喜欢什么酒，我知道他和荣格以及爱因斯坦分享。
Yeah. You know, kind of going up. I mean, I guess, I mean, he used to put up a yellow flag partly for his neighbor to, in effect, repel their children because they would come round and knock. And the yellow flag meant, you know, no, you know, I'm writing. You know, just... I didn't know that, yeah. Yeah, so there's these signals. And I think, you know, the enclosure that includes the loggia,
对红酒的热情，是的，好吧，我认为沃尔夫冈·泡利，因为他有非常有趣的双重性格，我想他可能喜欢任何酒，我应该这么想。但是，你知道，博林根被使用，你知道，我认为我们可以称它为一个精神场所或神圣场所。他和维克多·怀特（Victor White）的相遇，你知道，争议和《对约伯的回答》（Answer to Job）的创作与塔有很大关系，而且相当可悲的是，当他们闹翻时，嗯，当他们在那之后见面时，荣格只邀请维克多·怀特去库斯纳赫特（Kushnacht），他没有，你知道，他要失去他的权利，如果你愿意的话。所以从某种意义上说，塔在逻辑上被稍微政治化了。
really, he describes as, I felt a need for a piece of fenced in land but really he probably got fed up with people like me coming along the lake saying oh there's carl jung and his wife so he spent time in bollington with einstein too drinking red wine and talking about physics and ultimately coming up with the theory of synchronicity didn't he yeah well that was the einstein's paoli wasn't it I think Wolfgang Pauli I thought I thought Einstein was I don't know I know yeah so I didn't mean to I mean I I I'm not sure but I don't know what kind of wine Pauli liked it I know him and Jung and Einstein shared
意义上。但是是的，你知道，我的意思是，另一个有趣的事情是思考它如何成为一座塔，因为它不是一座塔。不是一座塔。如果你回顾这些信件，早些时候，他称之为我的乡村住宅，我的乡村小地方，然后几年后它变成了我的塔，带一个小t，然后它变成了“塔”。但这是一个正在那里被带出来的内在空间，它不是那么多的物理变化。我的意思是，他确实建造了一座塔，但当你看到它时，你看到的是一所房子，它并没有真正注册为一座塔。是的，真的，我的意思是，有塔状的元素。
a passion for red yeah well I think Wolfgang Pauli because he has really interesting double character I think he probably liked any wine, I should think. But, you know, Bollinger's used, you know, I think we could call it a spiritual place or a sacred place. And his encounters with Victor White and, you know, the controversy and the construction of Answer to Job have a lot to do with the tower and rather sadly when they kind of fall out um when they meet after that jung only invites victor white to kushnakt he doesn't you know he's going to have lost his rights if you like. So in a sense, the tower is slightly politicised in a logical
我的意思是，他们说精神之塔相当细长，但第一座塔相当粗短，但这没关系，因为，但我发现有趣的是，它开始培育它自己的符号，如果你愿意的话。
sense. But yeah, you know, I mean, another interesting thing to think about is the way that it becomes a tower, because it's not a tower. Not a tower. And if you go back through the letters, early on, he talks about as my country seat, my little place in the country, and then a few years later it becomes my tower with a little t, and then it becomes the tower. But it's an internal space that's being brought up there, it's not as much of a physical change. I mean he does build a tower but when you see it you see a house, it doesn't really register as a tower Yeah true, I mean there are tower-like elements
是的，你知道它开始培育它自己的符号，如果你愿意的话。嗯哼。是的。而且，你知道，他会在《回忆、梦、思考》（MDR）中宣称，你知道，他想以某种形式星座化或固化、具体化他的想法。而且，你知道，这有一种逻辑上的建筑移动。我认为这在某种程度上是真的，但我认为这是一种稍微构建出来的叙述。我的意思是，我并没有对你不敬，但我爱这个人，但我认为它是一个变得非凡的普通地方，你知道，而不是它是一个非凡的。
I mean they say the spiritual tower is quite slender and elongated but the first tower is quite stumpy but it doesn't matter because, but what I find interesting is that it starts to breed its own symbol if you like
我的意思是，人们说那座精神之塔相当细长，但第一座塔却很粗短，不过这没关系，因为，我感兴趣的是，它开始孕育出属于它自己的象征，如果你愿意这么说的话。
Yeah and you know that it starts to breed its own symbol, if you like. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And, you know, he would declare in MDR that, you know, he wanted to sort of constellate or solidify, concrete his ideas in form. And, you know, there's this kind of logical move to architecture. I think that's kind of true in a way but I think it is sort of a narrative that's slightly constructed. I mean I don't mean any disrespect to you but I love the man but I think it is an ordinary place that becomes extraordinary you know rather than it is an extraordinary
是的，你知道它开始孕育出属于它自己的象征，如果你愿意这么说的话。嗯。是的。而且，你知道，他在《MDR》中宣称，他想要以某种形式来汇聚、固化或具体化他的想法。而且，你知道，这是一种通向建筑学的逻辑举动。我认为在某种程度上这是对的，但我认为这是一种稍微构建出来的叙事。我的意思是，我并不是对你不敬，我很敬重那个人，但我认为这是一个平凡的地方变得非凡，而不是它本身就是一个非凡的地方。
place but you know you can't that's an interesting perspective i mean so i guess like two questions one you know what do you have any idea or any speculation what is in the tower you know what's up there that no one has seen or and two you you know, Carl Jung's a guy who sees all these patterns in life, religion, self, and starts to inventory them. You know, do you see patterns in Bollingen, have a sense of what he's doing? Is there quaternity symbolism or some kind of symbolic element that you feel like you've noticed that no one has seen yet? I'm not sure if I'm the only person to notice it, but I think I'm just going to read something actually which I've got on the screen
地方，但你知道你不能，这是一个有趣的视角。我的意思是，我想问两个问题：第一，你对塔里有什么东西有什么想法或推测吗？你知道上面有什么没人见过吗？第二，卡尔·荣格是一个在生活、宗教、自我中看到所有这些模式并开始盘点它们的人。你知道，你在博林根看到了什么模式吗？对他正在做的事情有什么感觉吗？有没有四元性象征或某种你觉得你已经注意到但还没有人发现的象征元素？我不确定我是不是唯一注意到它的人，但我认为我实际上要读一些我在屏幕上的东西
which might help. This is a letter to a guy called Peter de Brandt written in 1959 and this is a student of architecture who writes to him about sort of archetypal patterns in architecture. And his response broadly is the circle and the square are connected with the idea of shelter and protection, place of the hearth, concentration, the family and the small animals. And on a higher level with the symbol of the quatuor, I don't know if I pronounced that correctly, as the dwelling place of the inner man, the abode of gods. So I think in more direct answer to your question, I think the circle and the square oscillate and then sort of constellate into this triangle. So it's a kind of sort of essay in psychodeometry, but then you get these kind of intermediate spaces
这可能会有帮助。这是一封1959年写给一位名叫彼得·德·布兰特的建筑系学生的信，他写信给荣格询问建筑中的原型模式。荣格的回答大致是：圆和方与庇护和保护、炉边、集中、家庭和小动物的概念有关。在更高的层面上，它与四元性（quatuor）的象征有关——我不知道我发音是否正确——作为内在人的居住地，神的居所。所以我认为，更直接地回答你的问题，我认为圆和方在振荡，然后以某种方式聚集成这个三角形。所以这是一种心理几何学的尝试，但随后你会得到这些中间空间
that can't be geometrized, if that's a word. So it's kind of geometric and not in equal measure. But you do see the geometry kind of talking to it. You see his visual thought process there. That's fascinating. Yeah. And I think, you know, the role of France Young, his son, is very underestimated. There's a very lovely book that's just come out, which I'll mention, I can't find it, but anyway,
如果这是一个词的话，它们是无法几何化的。所以它在某种程度上既是几何的，又不是几何的，两者程度相当。但你确实看到了几何形状在与它对话。你在那里看到了他的视觉思维过程。这太迷人了。是的。而且我认为，弗朗茨·荣格（Franz Jung），也就是他儿子的作用被严重低估了。有一本刚出版的很可爱的书，我会提到它，我找不到它，但无论如何，
it's called About France and it's by an American woman, so you should be able to get it in your country, that talks about her visit or part of it talks about her visit to the tower with Franz Jung, who probably was involved with almost all of it. And so he could unpack some of the kind of narrative and some of the complexity of complicated geometry sort of crashing into each other. So I think in answer to your question, I think there's the circle and the square very evident and we can trace that back to the painting that he looks at in the rectory in Klein-Huneggen. It's a painting called the David with the Head of Goliath by Guido Reni, which has David leaning on a circular column
它叫《关于弗朗茨》（About France），是一位美国女性写的，所以你应该能在你们国家买到。书中谈到了她与弗朗茨·荣格一起参观塔楼的经历，或者其中一部分谈到了这次访问，弗朗茨·荣格可能参与了几乎所有的建造工作。所以他可以解读一些叙事和一些复杂的几何形状相互碰撞的复杂性。所以我认为回答你的问题，我认为圆和方非常明显，我们可以追溯到他在克莱因-胡内根（Klein-Huneggen）的牧师住宅里看到的画。那是一幅圭多·雷尼（Guido Reni）画的《大卫与歌利亚的头》，画中大卫靠在一根圆柱上，
with the head of Goliath on a square column. And he's absolutely transfixed by this in the dark, in the dark sequestered room. And I think in his youth, attics, towers, chapels, squares, circles gather. You know, in a way, I'm probably seeing that into it, but I think they gather around him. Castles, he draws castles. Architecture in the Red Book has a lot of, you know, a circle above a town,
而歌利亚的头放在一根方柱上。他在那个黑暗、与世隔绝的房间里被这幅画完全迷住了。我认为在他年轻时，阁楼、塔楼、礼拜堂、正方形、圆形聚集在一起。你知道，在某种程度上，我可能是在把它强加进去，但我认为它们聚集在他周围。城堡，他画城堡。《红书》中的建筑有很多，你知道，城镇上方的圆，
above a tower, above, you know, things. Yeah. And the fort that is drawn in the Red Book actually is a fort that pretty well existed during Jung's time. It was destroyed in the Treaty of Paris, but its ramparts existed.
塔楼上方，你知道，各种东西。是的。而且《红书》中画的堡垒实际上是荣格时代确实存在的一个堡垒。它在《巴黎条约》中被摧毁了，但它的城墙依然存在。
And it's not exactly like the picture in the Treaty of Paris that its ramparts existed and it's not exactly like the picture in the Red Book but he reconstructs it in his mind as this kind of star fort so I think he's looking you might say unconsciously in his formative years
它并不完全像《巴黎条约》中的图片，它的城墙依然存在，也不完全像《红书》中的图片，但他把它在脑海中重构为这种星形堡垒，所以我认为他在他形成期的那些年里，你可以说是在无意识地观察，
and consciously when he goes to the stupas of India and the the council house a council to call to the council and building in Fatima Sikri in India he's he's searching out sacred geometry but in his youth it's more it's sort of it's not so much in the background but it's more unconscious I suppose. Well can you clarify a stake of geometry just a little bit for people who may not be as aware of western esoteria? Yeah well I mean quickly put I think that
当他去印度的佛塔和法塔赫布尔西格里（Fatima Sikri）的议会大厦时，他是有意识地在寻找神圣几何，但在他年轻时，它更多的是在背景中，但我认为它更多是无意识的。好吧，你能为那些可能不太了解西方秘术的人稍微澄清一下神圣几何吗？是的，嗯，简而言之，我认为
you know if we go back to that that quote from jung to the to the student that the essence essence i suppose uh is contained the essence of man and the essence of god as a kind of mystical union is contained in um pure geometry you know it's a kind of absolute it's almost platonic isn't it it's a kind of absolute um so you know there are different permutations of that because then you go into sort of polygons and hexagons i mean for example the uh most baptistries are octagonal the eight you know seven plus one you know the rebirth and i believe well hannah but barbara hannah says that the spiritual tower you know which you can't go into it has eight facets inside i don't think it's octagonal but i think it has eight facets so you know that's a deliberate move the um the font when you go into the tower where he pumps water
你知道，如果我们回到荣格给那个学生的引言，本质，我想本质是包含在纯几何中的，人的本质和神的本质作为一种神秘的结合，你知道，这是一种绝对，几乎是柏拉图式的，不是吗？这是一种绝对，所以你知道，这有不同的排列组合，因为然后你会进入多边形和六边形，我的意思是，例如，大多数洗礼堂是八角形的，八，你知道，七加一，你知道，重生。我相信，嗯，汉娜，芭芭拉·汉娜说，精神之塔，你知道，你不能进去，里面有八个面，我不认为它是八角形的，但我认为它有八个面，所以你知道，这是一个故意的举动。当你进入塔楼时，那个他泵水的洗礼池
is eight-sided so you know i mean there's these these kind of you see him playing with space and geometry to convey meaning and math to a certain extent to convey meaning yeah i do and then every so often either he's away or you know of inverse, it's sort of,, because the inverse of the kind of awkward, kind of asymmetric things have to adjust to the next sort of chapter of the geometry. So it's a really complex and non-dualistic array, really, which I find fascinating yeah and so any idea what's at the top of the tower what the private
是八角形的，所以你知道，我的意思是，这些，你看到他在玩弄空间和几何来传达意义，在一定程度上用数学来传达意义。是的，我确实看到了，然后每隔一段时间，要么他不在，要么你知道，是反向的，这有点，因为那种尴尬的、不对称的东西的反向必须调整到几何的下一个章节。所以这确实是一个非常复杂且非二元论的阵列，我发现这很迷人。是的，那么对于塔顶有什么，博林根的私人房间是什么，你有什么推测或听到过什么传闻吗？我发现了一张第五层的照片，有趣的是，这是一种对宜居性的让步，因为它有，我相信
rooms in Bollingen are do you have any speculation or heard any rumors I found one picture of the fifth episode which interestingly is a kind of concession to habitability because it's got I believe
一个煤火炉。所以他们过去常常把煤吊上去，因为，你知道，荣格当时已经80岁左右了。所以，你知道，搬运木头并不是很可行。照片看起来确实部分内衬了木材，而且非常明显地俯瞰着湖泊，我发现这很感人，因为他谈到了死后的另一个博林根，以及这种通往彼岸的方面。对他来说，这是一个阈限空间。
a coal fire. And so they used to hoist up coal because, you know, Jung was, you know, 80, you know, around that time. So, you know, it wasn't really viable to move wood. And the picture looks as though it's certainly in part lined with timber and very much looks out over the lake and I find it quite moving because he talks about the other bollingen after death and that this kind of aspect to the beyond. It was a liminal space for him.
是的，是的，是的，它实际上是生与死之间的过渡。一位我忘了名字的传记作者记得看到荣格坐在精神之塔里，也就是下一层的二楼，完全沉浸在他的工作中，你知道，在这个另一个世界里。所以它有点像是通往塔楼的门户。是的，是的，然后你知道，他谈到了山脉和你知道，湖泊的壮丽，你知道，正如你所说，他想住在水边，还有山脉和彼岸的壮丽，讽刺的是，塔楼的石头就是从那里来的，你知道，湖对岸的采石场
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it was a transition between, in effect, life and death and one biographer, I've forgotten his name, remembers seeing Jung sat in the spiritual tower which is the next floor down on the second floor, absolutely absorbed in his work, you know, in this other world um so it's kind of a gateway to the tower yeah yeah and then you know he talks about the mountains and the you know the majesty of the lake that you know as you say he wants to live by water and the majesty of the mountains and the beyond which ironically is is where the stone came from for the tower you know the quarries on the other side of the lake
或者其中之一，所以它很令人回味，在某种意义上，第一座塔的关闭和第三座塔的超级关闭是开放的，你知道，这是一种舒张，不是吗？如果它们与其他元素一起打开和关闭，有时很难将建筑的所有元素融入对话中。好吧，但你看到空间在进行对话，但很难表达出来，因为它是一种视觉语言，它不是一种认知的，你知道，嗯，语言，基于词汇的语言。但听起来你确实很了解他在那里做什么以及他是如何看待它的，你知道，在你花时间在那里之后。是的，好吧，我想我们可以引入我们对话的另一件事是那个房子梦，
or one of them so it's evocative and and in a sense the closure of the first tower and the super closure of the third tower open and you know it's a kind of diastole isn't it really if they open and close with these other elements and it's hard sometimes to fit all the elements of architecture into a conversation well but you you see the space kind of having a conversation but it's hard to articulate it because it's a visual language it's not a cognitive you know um language uh word based language but it sounds like you have a real sense of what he's doing there and how he saw it you know after spending the time you've spent there yeah well i suppose the other thing we can draw into our conversation is the house dream
1909年他从美国回来时，你知道，我想塔楼的很多部分，我不认为塔楼是那个梦的复制品，但它里面有梦的元素，我认为有趣的是，它是一种重写本结构，你知道，一层叠着一层。当他发现那个士兵的尸体时，他给了地窖，在此之前，我的意思是，它不是字面意义上的地窖，但你知道，如果你想到那个梦，它有这种地下空间。而且，你知道，我认为，好吧，我已经写了整整一章关于那个梦的关系，
1909 when he's coming back with from america you know i think a lot of the tower i don't think the tower is a replica of the dream but it has elements of the dream in it and i think what's interesting about that is that it's kind of um palimpsest structure you know that one thing lying on top of another when he discovers the body of the um the the soldier he it gives the seller prior to that i mean it's not literally a cellar, but you know, it's got this kind of subterranean space if you think of the dream and You know, I think the Well, I've written a whole chapter on that the relationship of the dream
作为一种向导，如果你愿意的话，通往塔楼，而不需要它是一个建筑就是一个梦，你知道，所以这是另一个方面。好吧，有没有什么我们没有涉及到的，你觉得关于博林根很重要的东西？这些是我有的问题，除了在《回忆、梦、思考》和其他人关于你的写作中提到的内容之外，我对它了解不多。有什么你觉得很重要但我们没有提到的吗？是的。
as a kind of Guide if you like to the tower without it being a The building is a dream, you know so that's another aspect well is there anything that we don't get to that you feel like is important about volagen those are kind of the questions that i had i don't know a ton about it other than just what comes up in memories dreams reflections and other people's writing about you anything that you feel like is important we haven't hit on? Yeah.
嗯，我认为重要的是……这不是最好的答案，但我会从这里开始。是把它追溯到他更深层的心理和身体历史中。我认为博林根被配置为他工作的最后一个章节，如果你愿意的话。我认为它几乎是环绕式的，你知道，它是这种……它随着他的成长而成长。是的，而且我认为……
Well, I think what is important is to... This isn't the best answer, but I'll start with it. Is to trace it deeper into his psychic and physical history. I think Bollinger's configured as this kind of last chapter, if you like, of his work. I think it's much more almost circumlendically, you know, that it's this kind of... It grows as he grows. Yeah, and I think...
我有一种感觉，我还没有完全能够将其整合，那就是他，在某种意义上，建筑正在自我设计。它有一种建筑无意识。他在倾听这个地方，然后帮助它诞生。这不是他正在建造的蓝图。是的，是的，他谈到了这一点，因为当他写信给克里斯蒂娜·摩根（Christina Morgan）时，她也在美国建造了一座塔，嗯，他说，好吧，实际上当你开始建造时，你会知道它会释放出各种各样的灵魂，它不是进入灵魂，而是，嗯，小鬼之类的东西，你
I have a sense, I've not been entirely been able to constellate this, is that he, in a sense the building is designing itself. It has a kind of architectural unconscious. He was listening to the place and then helping it be birthed. It wasn't his blueprint that he was just building yeah yeah and he talks about that because when he writes to christina morgan who also built a tower in america um he says well actually when you start start your building you'll you'll know that it releases all sorts of spirits it doesn't go in the spirits but um ghoulies or something like that you
知道，所以这确实是天才……幽灵，也许是这个词？幽灵，是这个词吗？不，无论如何，你知道，我们明白了。所以我认为他在倾听，这是一种建筑行为，但我认为
know so there is this literally genius... Spectres, maybe, is that the word? Spectre, is that the word? No, anyway, you know, we get the idea. And so I think he's listening, which is an architectural act, but I think
它比那丰富得多。我认为建筑在引导他的思想，回应他的思想。你知道，如果你观察他在《全集》中追踪的图表，它们变得更加三维了。所以我认为存在这种交通。他正在对空间和建筑给予宗教般的关注。绝对是这样。是的。第二个点是塔楼的遗产。所以玛丽·路易丝·冯·弗朗茨（Marie-Louise von Franz）建造了一座塔，
it's much richer than that. I think the building is leading his ideas, responding to his ideas. You know, if you look at his diagrams as you trace them through the collective works, they become much more three-dimensional. So I think there's this kind of traffic. He's paying religious attention to the space and the building. Absolutely, yeah. And then a second point is the kind of legacy of the tower. So Marie Van Frans built a tower,
嗯，是由弗朗茨·荣格的儿子设计的。我非常感谢住在那里并与我分享这些图纸的戈蒂（Gotti），这些图纸是这座塔的美丽图纸。所以她的塔成为了垂直商业中的完美塔楼，因为它是这个四元体，你知道，它不需要进化。
well, it was designed by Frans Jong's son. And I'm very grateful to Gotti who lives there, who shared with me the drawings, which are beautiful drawings of this tower. So her tower becomes the kind of perfect tower in vertical commerce, because it's this quadrate, you know, it doesn't have to evolve.
它只是这种固定。而克里斯蒂娜·摩根的塔是一个非常细长的圆形东西。所以圆和方又回来了，你知道，在这种遗产中。我的意思是，我只是觉得它们都很迷人。我想，你知道，我认为玛丽·路易丝·冯·弗朗茨对荣格说，好吧，有点厌倦了，
It's just this fixing. And Christina Morgan's tower is this very slender, circular thing. So the circle and the square come back, you know, in this kind of legacy. I mean, I just think they're all fascinating. And I suppose, you know, I think Marie-Verun France got a bit fed up with Jung saying, well,
你知道，你的塔需要像这样，这是我的塔。你知道，离它远点。但我认为，回答你的引导的主要观点是，它是互惠的，它是地方、心理、思想之间的互惠，它是一种心理场所，你知道，嗯，而且我想它不是一个单一的野心。它是关于自然世界的声音，湖水拍打的声音，那些来访的人，托尼·沃尔夫（Toni Wolfe）。托尼·沃尔夫在塔楼中的角色一定非常巨大。弗朗茨·荣格，你知道，建筑工人们，你知道。
you know, your tower needs to be like, this is my tower. You know, just get out of it. But I think that the main point, to answer your lead is is that it's the reciprocity it's a reciprocity between place psyche ideas it's a kind of psychic place you know and um and i suppose it's not a singular ambition It's about the voice of the natural world, the lake lapping in, those who visit, Tony Wolfe. Tony Wolfe's role must have been enormous in the tower. Franz Jung's, you know, the builders, you know.
所以这种孤独的人物带着这种孤独的象征的想法，我认为是还原论的。好吧，是的，那是一个活生生的，它肯定是一个活生生的象征。那么对于那里有什么还没被看到的东西有什么推测吗，或者有什么传闻，还是你喜欢那种神秘感？你知道，它从来没有完全开放或为人所知？我喜欢这种神秘感。最初，我打算问荣格家族，也许有一天我会足够勇敢地这样做，
So this idea of this kind of solitary figure with this solitary kind of symbol of that is reductive i think well yeah that's a living it's a living symbol for sure so any speculation on on things that are there that hasn't haven't been seen or any rumor or do you like the mystery of that you know, it's not ever fully open or known? I like the mystery. Initially, I was going to ask the Jung family, and maybe one day I'll be brave enough to do this,
说，我能测量整个建筑吗，画一张整个建筑的图纸吗？这样就会有一张蓝图。我不认为有蓝图，因为我想我已经试着追踪过其中一些，会有建筑许可，但在
to say, could I measure the whole of this building, do a drawing of the whole of the building? So there'd be like a blueprint of it. I don't think there are blueprints because I think I've tried to track some of them would have had building some estimates would have had building permits but there was a fire in the
圣加仑档案馆发生了一场火灾，我不知道它们是否在里面，但我有种感觉，它们不存在，或者现在不存在了。但后来，也许这是事后合理化，我只是认为，事实上，我的一个曾孙丹尼尔对我说，
St. Garland archive and I I don't know if they were in there but I think I have the sense that they don't exist or don't exist now. But then more recently, maybe this is post justified. I just think, in fact, one of my great grandsons, Daniel said to me,
嗯，它对不同的人意味着不同的东西。我认为它必须是普遍的，而且，嗯，在某种程度上不是普遍的，你知道，它既是非常个人的，也是普遍的，所以我对这种神秘感没问题。但这很好。好吧，你知道，这有点，嗯，每次我去，我都会看到别的东西，你知道，显然，你知道，你只是在和人交谈，你试图保持礼貌和尊重，你不能拍照，但从侧面，如果你是的话，你会注意到一些东西，你知道，它总是给予。它总是活过来。
well, it means different things to different people. I think it has to just be universal and it's, well, not universal in a way, you know, it's very sort of personal as well as being universal so i'm kind of fine with the mystery but that's nice well you know it's kind of um every time i go i see something else and you know obviously you know you're just one slightly in conversation with people and you're trying to be polite and respectful and you can't take photographs, but out of the side, if you are, you notice something can, you know, it's always giving. It's always coming alive.
而且它还在使用。它不是博物馆。我的意思是，它仍然按照他预想的那样使用，被家人几乎原样保留作为度假屋。有时他们在那里度假，有时它是空的。是的，我的意思是，我认为如果它变成博物馆会非常遗憾，我认为荣格不会高兴。你知道，显然弗洛伊德的维也纳故居已经发生了这种情况，
And it's still used. It's not a museum. I mean, it's, it's still used as he intended, left almost as is by the family for a holiday house. Sometimes they're on holiday there and sometimes it's empty. Yeah, I mean, I think that it would be a great shame if it, I think Jung would not be pleased if it became a museum. You know, obviously that's happened to Freud's Vienna home
实际上伦敦的家也是如此，这很好，所以这不是为了贬低那些走这条路的人，但我认为，我的意思是，向我解释的方式是，带人参观会很困难，因为楼梯太窄了，但我认为这实际上是一种，你知道，某种推卸问题的方式。这是荣格家族永远的家，你知道，所以它应该是吗？是的，但是，嗯，但你知道，话虽如此，正如你所观察到的，他们非常乐于助人，嗯，你知道，如果你敲门，嗯，你知道，我认为这令人难以置信，我们大多数人不会那样做，不是吗？我们会说……特别是考虑到来的人这么多。
and actually the London home as well, which is is fine so it's not to decry people who've gone down that route but I think I mean the way it was explained to me is that it would be difficult to show people around because the stairs are so narrow but I think that's really a kind of you know sort of batting away the problem this is a home for the for the young family forever you know and so should it be you know yes but um but you know that said as you've observed that they're very accommodating in um you know if you knock on the door um you know which i think is incredible most of us wouldn't do that wouldn't't we? We'd say... Especially with this amount of people who come.
是的。是的，是的。我的意思是，我认为当人们同时来时，他们会尝试组织事情。但当然，对我来说，我总是只想要一次个人谈话，你知道，只是为了，你知道，拜托，拜托，拜托，你知道，
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I think they try and organise things when people come at the same time. But of course, for me, I always wanted just a personal conversation, you know, just to, you know, please, please, please, you know,
告诉我一些事情，这会满足我的热情，如果你愿意的话。好吧，有没有什么我们可以指引那些想更多了解你的工作或预订你的书或网站的人？我的意思是，我们可以把他们引向哪里？对你在这里所说的话感兴趣的人。好吧，我很乐意让你分享我的电子邮件，嗯，嗯，我应该读出来吗，或者你可以，或者我也可以把它放在播客说明里，节目说明里，如果你想要的话。是的，嗯，因为目前我希望我的博士学位能，嗯，好吧，至少在1月或2月之前写完，然后我真的希望它能成为一本书，所以回答关于书的问题，那还在等待中。我有时会做讲座，
tell me something that is, it will feed my passion if you like well is there anything that we can point people to who want to find more about your work or pre-order your book or a website i mean where can we redirect them people that are interested in what you've what you've said here well i'd be happy for you to share my email um um should i read that out or or you can or i can also put it in the in the podcast notes the show notes if you want yeah um because the the moment i'm hoping that my phd will be um well at least written uh by perhaps january february and then I'm really hoping it becomes a book so in answer to question about a book that's waiting. I do sometimes lectures
我做过的讲座都被录下来了，如果有人需要，我很乐意为他们做讲座，因为显然很多东西是非常视觉化的，所以如果我们需要更多地说明事情，我可以这样做。但是，我知道你先接触了露西，露西·哈斯金森（Lucy Huskinson），我的导师，她写了很多关于这方面的文章，所以我认为那里有一切。抱歉，嗯，尼采，就像她做很多尼采在建筑方面的研究，也一样。是的，是的，事实上，她正在完成一本关于那方面的书，所以她的书，《模仿自我的建筑》（The Architecture of the Mimetic Self），我认为是一本非常非常重要的书。然后显然我有偏见，但我确实觉得，然后克莱尔，克莱尔·马库斯·库珀（Claire Marcus Cooper）写了一篇很美的论文叫《房子，自我的象征》，作为PDF很容易找到，所以这些，然后最近托马斯·巴里（Thomas Barry）写了关于这个意义上的建筑，但就塔楼本身而言，
I've done have been recorded and I'd happily do a lecture for someone if you know that because obviously a lot of this is quite visual and so if we needed to illustrate things more I could do that. But a person that would be, I know that you approached Lucy first, Lucy Huskinson, my supervisor, writes a lot on it so i think that there's everything pardon uh nichi like she does a lot nichi in architecture also yeah yeah she in fact she's in the process of um finishing a book on that so her book um the architecture of the mimetic self uh i think is an important very very important book and then obviously i'm biased but i i do feel that and then claire uh claire marcus cooper wrote a beautiful paper called house symbol of self um which is available comparatively easy as a pdf so those and then more recently thomas bar Barry has written about architecture in this sense but in terms of the tower itself
我希望那是我的工作，因为如果别人做了，那就像在船侧面开了一个洞，但当然它会来自不同的视角，会有所不同，所以我认为我们可能必须等待，我不知道，六个月左右，但希望，你知道，2023年这本书会，嗯，这本书会上市，所以，嗯，一定要谷歌一下，如果人们想要个性化的演讲或演示，我也会分享你的电子邮件地址。是的，抱歉，嗯，关于1920、18，不，2023年，有什么可爱的，那将是塔楼建成100周年，所以这是我的，这是我的目标，但这是一种光荣的痴迷，我已经变得戏剧化了。我已经放弃了一切来做这件事。所以我认为关于它的故事，或者一个故事需要被讲述，
I'm hoping that's my job because it would put a hold of this in the side of the ship if somebody else was yeah but of course it would come from a different perspective and be different so I think we have to probably wait um I don't know six months or something but hopefully you know 2023 the book will be uh the book will be for sale so um definitely Google and I'll share your email address too if people want a personalized talk or presentation yeah sorry um what would be um lovely about the 1920 18 no 2023 is it would be 100 years after the tower so that's my that's my kind of um aim but it's i i it's a glorious obsession that I've been dramatic. I've sort of given up everything to do. So I think the story or a story needs to be told about it,
这确实是我们谈话的原因，不是吗？但是，你知道。好吧，马丁，你的热情很美。我真的很感谢你与大家分享这一点。而且，你知道，我肯定会链接到你的电子邮件地址，然后我希望有一天能读到你的书。所以谢谢你，乔，给我这个机会。我的意思是，显然，能够简洁地总结一个人正在做的事情是有帮助的。所以我想要感谢你给我这个机会，嗯，谁知道呢，你知道，嗯，我认为我们需要，你知道，这确实是一个生态论点，不是吗？
which is really why we're talking, isn't it? But, you know. Well, Martin, your passion is beautiful. I really appreciate you sharing that with everybody. And, you know, I will definitely get linked to your email address and then I hope to read your book one day. So thank you, Joe, for the opportunity. I mean, obviously, what helps is to be able to succinctly summarize what one's doing. So I want to thank you for the opportunity um and who knows you know um i think we need you know it's an ecological argument really isn't
如果你真的放大了看，我们如何属于我们自己和地方，你知道，这确实是我们正在谈论的。所以，但谢谢你。是的，当然。我也谢谢你。非常感谢你的时间。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
if you really zoomed up how do we belong to ourselves and to place you you know, that's really what we're talking about. And so, but thank you. Yeah, of course. And I thank you. Thank you so much for your time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你真的深入探讨，我们如何归属于我们自己和某个地方，你知道，这才是我们真正讨论的内容。所以，谢谢你。是的，当然。我也谢谢你。非常感谢你抽出时间。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。